we're with now is the labor party
national campaign coordinator and MP for
Birmingham ladywood Shabana Mahmoud a
very good morning to you so what's your
verdict on the night so far from Labor's
point of view I think this is a very
very strong set of results for the labor
party it shows that we are on course for
a majority labor government at the next
general election as you've been telling
your views we've been winning all over
the country taking areas that we've not
held uh before not since before 1997
Medway in Kent we've been winning in the
Midlands in Stoke and also up in the
north where we've taken the
Middlesbrough mayorality so if you look
at the spread of the results and the
areas that we're winning we're winning
all over the country and I think that
puts us on track for a majority of the
next election yes and that's that's a
big claim because in order to win a
majority of the next general election
labor need an enormous swing it'll be a
bigger swing than Tony Blair managed to
pull off in 1997. are you really sure
you're on track for that we've never
been complacent about the scale of the
challenge that we Face 2019 was one of
our worst ever defeats in our whole
history and people had written the labor
party off for a generation or more so
under Care's leadership we have got
ourselves not only back on the pitch but
we are winning voters back in the areas
that we need to win that next general
election if you take these results and
you map them on to constituencies you'll
see that we are winning in seats like
stevenage in Grimsby in Hartley pool
we'd also be winning both of the seats
in Dudley Dudley North and Dudley South
and to take those seats at a general
election we need a 15 swing so we are
achieving the scale of swings that we
need in order to win the next general
and yet talking to Greg Hans sitting in
that chair in the last hour he said
before Tony Blair's win labor gained
1661 seats
um the conservative lost more than 1900
seeds he said I don't think we're
anything like that from these results so
far well the context is a little bit
different between 1997 and today but
with these results we are on course to
be the largest party in local government
we are on course to have our best local
elections performance since 1997 and I
would say that actually does put us on
calls for a majority of the next
election and the flip side of that is if
the Tories are losing the sorts of
numbers of counselors that even Greg
hands appears to be admitting might
happen this morning then I think that
shows the danger that Rishi sunak is in
and the fact that this change of leader
hasn't actually resulted in a change of
Fortune for the Tory party local
elections are different though aren't
they I mean you take councils like
Plymouth there are a huge number of
local issues going on there the
controversy over tree felling in in the
town of for starters generally the
turnout's lower as well so you can point
to individual results and you can pick
out wins that you're pleased about but
that doesn't really translate in a
general election does that well we have
to go away the data shows us and it is
you know it's perfectly reasonable for
us to map these results onto
constituencies your analysts would be
doing that if I wasn't doing it and what
they are showing is that we are
achieving in some of these
constituencies huge swings far bigger
than what we actually need in order to
take them in a general election Plymouth
more views very much a constituency
that's in our sites for that general
election gets us into majority labor
government territory if we're taking
seats like that so I think you have to
look at the spread of where the votes
are that we're winning you have to look
at what the map looks like and I think
that that shows that this is an
incredibly strong foundation for it as
we look here to the general election
this could be a high water mark for you
couldn't it given the fact that the
economy is set to improve between now
and a general election and inflation to
come down well look the cost of living
is the number one issue focusing voters
all over the country and I think it's so
telling that the Tories didn't spend a
single day talking about the cost of
living crisis and that's because they
crushed the economy in Autumn of last
year Rishi sunak doesn't know how to fix
it and on the major issue of the day the
Tories have had nothing to say and I
think that's a real tell for what they
are presenting to voters meanwhile we've
got an alternative a positive plan on
things that we would be doing to help
people with the number one and yet a lot
of the campaign has involved labor
attacking the Tories not least in those
controversial online ads specifically
targeting rishi's tsunag I mean there
seems to be a lot of reasons that
Labor's putting forward for not voting
Tory but how clear a picture are we
actually getting about what labor would
do well firstly I'm you know making no
apologies for holding the Tories
robustly to account for their track
record over 13 years in government that
have led to failure and a whole range of
areas including the criminal justice
system but also on the economy at which
they crashed in Autumn and for which
they've got no answers but you're right
we are also focusing on the things that
we are saying we would do in government
both now and also if we're in the next
general election to ease the pressure
that's on families with the cost of
living crisis but but is that clear I
mean the the tour has been calling it's
a flip-flop haven't they because he's
backtracked on a few of his promises
just this week he's we've seen a climb
down on his promise to abolish the
student tuition fees Kia has made it
very clear we're not going to make any
promises at the general election in our
Manifesto that we cannot keep and the
changed economic circumstances partly as
a result of the Tories crashing the
economy in Autumn last texture do mean
that we have to make different choices
and some things that we might have
wanted to do a couple of years ago or
more are no longer going to be possible
so I think it's actually being open and
upfront and honest with the electorate
about what is and what is not going to
be feasible and what his priorities for
government are going to be which are
about getting the economy growing to get
us out of this Doom Loop of stagnation
that the Tories have got us in getting
that economy growing sorting out our
public services and helping families
with the cost of living crisis what do
you think is bringing back voters to
labor from places that went Tori in 2019
and the results so far is it simply that
kissed armor isn't Jeremy corbyn it's
the combination of 13 years of Tory
failure and having a credible
alternative in kirst armor in the labor
party Under kirst Armor I've been
hearing from voters in Stoke where I've
spent quite a lot of time over the last
couple of weeks you know people who left
us for the first time in 2019 but who
can see that undercares leadership the
labor party has changed that it's you
know interested in those people again in
their concerns and that we are speaking
to the concerns that voters have and
that we have a plan to deal with those
concerns as well so it's a combination
of all of those things which is why I
think it's such a good and solid set of
results for us as we look ahead to the
next general election